les faits reprochés à la poste sont
graves
travail dissimulé quand l'inspection du
travail débarque à la plateforme de
préparation et de distribution du
courrier de besançon le 16 mars 2010
elle constate des dépassements
d'horaires massif deux tiers des
facteurs relevant du droit privé sont en
heures supplémentaires ce jour là
certains déclarent travailler jusqu'à
une heure et demie de plus chaque jour
un travail non déclaré faute de
pointeuse et donc non rémunéré des
accusations balayées d'un revers de main
par l'avocat parisien du groupe qui n'a
pas daigné répondre à nos questions à la
barre il a expliqué que l'ensemble des
salariés concernés avaient perçu des
heures supplémentaires et que le temps
de travail collectif doit s'apprécier
sur des cycles de 8 à 12 semaines
un argumentaire convaincant pour le
procureur mais truffée de contrevérités
pour le syndicat sud ptt partie civile à
ce procès qui met en avant le malaise
des postiers provoquée par la
réorganisation de l'entreprise à la fin
des années 2000 avant ça se passe est
globalement bien pour les facteurs on
avait une charge de travail qui étaient
corrects les gens ne se plaignait pas
les choses les choses ont changé
réellement en fin d'année 2008 et me
donniez 2009 avec la fameuse
réorganisation facteur d'avenir
sachant que depuis tous les deux ans il
ya des réorganisations d'envergure et ça
aussi c'est très déstabilisant
donc on change on découpe on déplace les
facteurs celui qui avait une tournée un
jour donné le lendemain il en aura une
autre ainsi de suite pour les gens par
exemple qui sont remplaçants qui arrive
au pour prendre une retournée au pied
levé c'est extrêmement compliqué donc je
pense que oui il y à des dépassements
systématique des horaires de travail des
facteurs ont peut-être pas pour tout
simple en tout cas pour une grande
partie d'entre ces accusations de
travail dissimulé elles sont
complètement théorique complètement hors
sol pour l'avocat de la direction de à
la poste bien sûr qu'on est loin très
loin des cadences infernales dénoncé par
certains le ministère public à lui
requis le non lieu dans cette affaire le
tribunal a mis sa décision en délibéré
au 5 juillet prochain